i want to do this example question for
two reasons number one
it's got a different coefficient here
for x okay
so you might get different numbers of
solutions that what you might normally
expect it was just a single x
and number two i plan for this to be
sort of the you know how i try and give
you sort of a series of steps
okay here's what you need to go through
here's my um one two three four and then
that's how i approach questions like
this
i want to use this as the example for
auxiliary angle
okay now if this is the setup what's the
very first thing that we do
if we're going to treat this question
with auxiliary angle
very first thing
okay so we want to introduce something
right let's
now obviously this right hand side is
just the number that you're going to
choose okay so it's not to do with that
it's this left hand side right so i'm
going to let that
coefficient and all be equal to
now here's where you have to do some
thinking okay so you've got four
different
forms that you can choose from which
form what do you choose
yeah it's good yeah okay i think i heard
it a couple of a few different places
the first thing you notice is there's a
sign out the front okay
so i'm gonna have our sign
so you pay attention to the order and
then the second thing you look at is the
fact that in between them
is a minus sign okay so i'm going to
pick an expansion here which will just
let me treat
a and b as the positive coefficients
here and i don't have to worry about
negatives i'm going to get an acute
angle
which would be nice in each i don't have
to work out worry about what quadrant
i'm in
okay so to get a minus for sine i'm
going to have
x minus alpha okay so far so good
i think we should so those are the two
things that we're looking for
okay now what
okay so you've got two steps once you
get sort of sorry not two steps two
choices
once you get really comfortable with um
using auxiliary angle
you can skip the expansion step okay but
since i still think we're trying to
learn it
let's just make sure we get our
coefficients right and match them up
properly and expand the right hand side
question
um
no do you mean the pythagorean identity
part is that the part you're asking
about yeah okay
the answer is no i'll show you the
amount of working that i would expect
you can go straight to r equals the
square root of et cetera et cetera but
i'll get to that in a few lines
um good question sorry i probably should
have put that there
does that make you better thanks for
picking that up and that'll also affect
the number of solutions that we give
the thumbs up to at the end okay all
right so do you get your coefficients to
match up
i'm going to expand the right hand side
okay so over here i'm going to get r out
the front
okay and this is just my regular
expansion sign
cos cos
sine okay
so from there i might just make these
coefficients a little more obvious
i'm gonna go to r okay so i've got
um my coefficients lined up here okay
in order to work out what cos alpha and
sine alpha are they're going to have r
in them right so i might as well work
out r to begin with
r is just going to be the square root of
a squared plus b squared right i'm going
to go three
plus one
okay so since i wrote down straight away
that it's a positive square root
that's why i mentioned that has to be
greater than 0. okay
so r is equal to 2 that's good now i can
bring that down into my two equations
involving alpha right so i can say
let's see here r cos alpha should be
root three right so in fact i can go
straight to this line because alpha is
equal to
root three on two see where i got that
from
okay if you don't feel comfortable quite
jumping there you can say
r cos alpha which is two cause alpha and
then have this as the next line
okay either of those are fine now
because we picked we picked the form
right we got to choose between the four
and we picked the natural form
therefore i already know that my alpha
is going to be acute
okay so i sort of actually don't need to
worry about what my sine alpha
coefficient is but just for the sake of
it just to be sure
you jot down your other one sine alpha
that corresponds to the one
right so that's gonna be one over two
and you can see that they agree with
each other if they don't
you've picked your coefficients wrong or
you've matched up things incorrectly
okay
so alpha is acute
so what is alpha radiance
radians pioneer
don't bring me out here pie on six
hurray
gives me a real nice warm fuzzy feeling
when i see my students getting the right
answer okay great
so plan on six i've got my r so now i
can rephrase
my i'm using this identity and pop it
straight into the equation right
so instead of that left-hand side i'll
say this
okay no sorry that's just a wonky
bracket
okay so that was the auxiliary angle
part of it okay so let's just
finish it all off divide through so
you've got this
okay so watch out here by the way
because you're in 2x
okay so this domain here you're going to
get it's going to wiggle
many times right or twice as many times
as normal so you're going to get a
couple of solutions where you would
normally only expect one
right so this is what sine looks like
okay so where's regular sine x where's
it equal to one
well up here right and what angle is
that
one two right
okay but we've got sine 2x okay
so that's going to repeat again so
you're expecting another answer namely
that
plus 2 pi so that plus 4 pi on 2 so
that's 5.2 right
see that so therefore i'm going to note
both of these answers down
when i come down here to solve so i've
got 2x minus pi on 6
equals
okay so now i just need to tidy up
get rid of that auxiliary angle add it
to both sides so that's going to give me
let's see let's come 2 pi on 3.
this will become
eight pi on three i think double check
that one
okay that makes sense and then i'm just
gonna divide
pie on three four five
okay and i guess i ought to um the
reason why i've got these dots here is
because i'm thinking in my head there
are many solutions to this
but here i'm just restricting it to the
two so i might as well put in my domain
restriction here
okay and there are my two answers right
so let's just review quickly what were
the steps that we went through
number one you introduce your form okay
so you gotta choose
which is the most natural one to make
the solution for this question easier
obviously as i said before if they
stipulate to you especially in such a
such form
you don't have to pick but you still
have to go through these steps here
okay then in here what's this next step
okay we're trying to work out
our new amplitude
and phase okay that's our r
and our alpha we just use this expansion
here to equate coefficients you've done
that before
okay and then here finally you just
solve the equation
okay which is actually the part that you
already knew how to do there's nothing
to do with auxiliary angle here in terms
of the methods
and you remember me telling you the
whole point of this method is to phrase
a question like that
as a question like this which you
already know how to solve but you learn
how to solve last year
okay